the other top table here just along the
officers table introduce themselves
please let's go start with you - mr.
legal services Thank You chairman I'm
Dale Barca I'm a team leader my role is
as an impartial adviser to the committee
and to help answer any questions that
arise I'm bound by the code of
Professional Conduct of the role Town
Planning Institute and during the
meeting I may be asked to comment on
points raised seek clarifications and
advise on planning practice to ensure
that the decision made by committee is
sound committee members are not bound by
the case officers recommendation or by
any oral advice Thank You senior planner
mark Weller lumbus with Hansen the
council's liability consultant Eddie
wrench senior Tamplin James Hoskins
planner David Jeffries senior town
planner perfect thank you very much
everybody
right so unless I'm getting out of sync
I think we go now to item 1 apologies
for absence please thank you I know that
we're waiting for counts Lipari I'm sure
we've all been stuck in traffic over the
last few days around strap line I know
there's an accident tonight as well so
she'll join us when she can discovery of
interest is please for members any at
all yes counselor Crump okay if they
know the disclosures that's fine
just draw your attention to that did I'm
assuming that all committee members
received letter from the if any if any
Hampton Parish Council I think is it
sorry
Carla's planning for the applicant they
receive that okay so it's four seven all
right well obviously thank you
next item eighteen three minutes of the
meeting held on 13th of December to have
you thank you very much I'll sign
there's the end right before we jump
into the agenda proper I'm just gonna
make a few very quick changes if the
committee are okay
with that I'd like to move item five up
to the next item and they will deal with
item seven shortly after that then we
will follow them normal numerical
running order if that's okay with
everybody the reasons for which will
become obvious as we move along so if
that's okay we're going into our first
application tonight in this item five
found on page 33 of your agendas and
this is application reference 17 / 0 0 1
7 8 / s 1 0 6 a to the harborage cement
works fish is eaten is for the variation
of a 106 agreement sexualize experiment
cosmic can ask you to update as alice
thank you as per the update sheet since
the agenda went to print the applicant
has proposed an additional 11 affordable
units in the form of discount to market
price of 30 percent or the equivalent
off-site financial contribution on this
basis councilor kettle has confirmed his
agreement for the diva variation to be
approved under delegated powers and as a
result there is an updated
recommendation that the planning manager
be authorized to determine the deed of
variation under delegated powers Thank
You chair
Thank You Alan can I just confirm very
quickly that the only reason this would
have come to committee it's not through
scale of development it's only as a
result of it being a request from the
board member thank you right if the
committee are content with that and
happy
to propose that we delegate that
decision to officers seconded by
Councillor bonds you're all contempt to
go to vote on that yes they were
tornament
so therefore the committee resolves to
delegate application efforts 17 / 0 0 1
7 8 / s 1 0 6 a 4 decision by officers
we can then move to item 7 on your
gender as well which is found on page 57
this is application reference then 17 /
0 2 3 6 2 / ful is to the land next to
the lank at Mill Lane
Afeni Compton under direction of for
residential dwellings and associated
infrastructure presenting officers James
Hodgkins
I believe we're going to be looking at
deferring this as well can I ask you to
give me that's right Thank You chair
again it's it's covered in the updates
in front of you members since the report
was published we've received some advice
from from our policy team indicating
that we need to do further research into
the policy issues surrounding this
application to establish whether or not
the principle of development is
acceptable
we're therefore requesting members to
defer the application to allow us to do
that work and in the event that the
principle objection is overcome the
application can be decided under
delegated powers as both the Parish
Council and the local member are
supporting the application thank you
Jeff Thank You Dale what seems very
sensible again happy to propose that we
defer that do I have a seconder for that
councillor Mills just beat you to it
if everyone's happy to vote on that as
well all those in favor of defend thank
you so therefore the committee results
to differ after case reference 17 / 0 2
3 6 2 F / fu well don't get too excited
committee that's that's their the quick
ones out okay let's resume the normal
numerical running order okay so that
means
we just know that's all so I keep going
back to the lovely so let's go back to
item 4 this is found on page 7 of your
agenda tonight and is application
reference 17 / 0 1 9 3 0 / REM is the
land between Daventry Road and Welsh
Road East it's for reserved matters
application for 535 Wellington to an
approval previously I'm not gonna read
out all the numbers including matters
relating to the layout landscaping
appearance and scale reserved by
condition and including internal road
network housing layout and types green
infrastructure to child children's play
areas indoor sports pitch that's why
outdoor sport pictures together with
parking landscaping and open space
presenting officer David Jeffrey David
ft thank you so much a chair yes as he
concisely said in a nutshell this is
application 1701 9 3o REM which is the
phase 2 reserved matters detailed for
the 535 dwellings including landscape
and layout so on for land between
Daventry Road and Welsh Road East the
application site sits to the east of
Southam between Daventry Road and Welsh
Road east and east of the flying fields
housing estate the proposal delivers on
sou 3 the core strategy policy housing
allocation the application site boundary
is shown here
members will note the properties on race
both close and Knapton rise which are
the closest dwellings of the flying
fields estate public footpath also shown
running across the side in site listed
buildings are shown in red and the town
centre conservation area is picked out
in pink
this slide shows an aerial view of the
application site which comprises a
single large agricultural field bounded
by native hedges adjacent to Welsh Road
East is a small area of hard standing in
an agricultural building to the south
this is in sight Park there are some
live work units there and a distribution
and storage building to the east and the
north we have open countryside this is
the view from the hard standing area
within the site
it shows the open fields and the flat
nature of the site turning towards the
agricultural buildings and towards
insight Park that live work units this
view from within the site shows the
western boundary with the flying fields
estate scene looking towards apt and
rise there and further round towards
rains bullet rains book close and
towards land associated with the
bailiffs house this views from within
the site near to damaged Road looking
across the site towards the bailiffs
house and towards insight Park and the
wider sight the boundary hedge with
Daventry Road this slide shows the
parameters plan which accompanied the
outline application and which was and
which the outline approval conditioned
development should be in general
accordance with this slide shows the
phase 1 approved plan that was approved
under delegated powers with the consent
of the parish council and
excuse me town council I should say it
details the layout of a significant
element of the primary Road and the
frontage damage erode including
landscape and drainage and temporary
accesses for sales and construction
moving now to this application
this proposal fleshes out the scheme a
great deal it shows the whole of the
site here the layout shows 535 dwellings
across the site including open spaces
play areas and an appropriate Street
hierarchy the scheme achieves 34
dwellings per hectare and 187 of those
dwellings are affordable in a mix of ten
years amendments to the scheme during
the lifetime of the application have
created a more balanced open space
provision I was referred to in the
agenda report reflecting the latest
advice of policy a landscape offer is
incorporated here into the gardens of
future residents between the proposed
developments and the flying fields
estate this detail was agreed at the
request of the Parish Council who
initially objected to this the proposal
details of a shop which will eventually
be provided in this location and the
community hall sports pavilion which
will be eventually provided in this
location will follow as required by the
section 106 the scheme incorporates for
character area types with a central line
tree-lined primary route through the
site from Daventry Road to Welsh Road
East as a key feature secondary streets
are also shown the Mews courtyard
dwellings and dwellings approaching the
open space frontage design particularly
for that
roar allege the properties are a mix of
bungalows in sari a mix of properties in
bungalows two stories and two-and-a-half
story dwellings this slide shows a
visualization of views from wind the
public realm looking west towards the
development the properties are proposed
in a mix of red brick gray and red tiles
and render they include bay windows
coins dormers as architectural features
this flaw
this slide shows views of the entrance
to the development from Welsh Road East
and this slide shows a view from Dimitri
Road looking into the scheme across the
triangular plot reserved for a retail
unit returning to the overall plan it's
notable how significantly the proposal
adheres to the outline plan considered
at committee landscaping to the east
along Dimitri Road has been
significantly strengthened through
amendments and drainage and electricity
and gas compounds have been sensitively
cited that concludes the presentation
there are a number of updates on the
update sheet including representations
from the Town Council and to further
recommended conditions relating to the
landscape boundary with flying fields
and another condition proposed to secure
an approved CCTV scheme a pound way
subject to those additional conditions
officers consider the recommendation
within the committee report to be robust
therefore chair the recommendation is
that the planning manager be authorized
to grant approval to the reserved
matters details subject to the
conditions and notes within the report
and the additional conditions detailed
within the update sheet thank you thank
you David
excellent let's go to our first speaker
now previously we had the champ at the
challenge counter stood registers feet
they've now withdrawn their I wish to
speak so we go to our object as we start
mr. Ian Beatty please you'd like to come
on up and take a seat at the table
yes is mrs. Crips here yet is it
Oh issue so your deputizing alright if
yes if you both want to take a seat now
you have you've got three minutes
between you have you worked out how you
want to divide this up equally all right
I'll try to give you a 10-second warning
before the halfway point if you like
alright in that case if actually stay
seated 20 questions at the end what to
say I'll give you a warning
towards the halfway point as well
alright people that's it brilliant okay
gents over to you okay I'm Ian BT of
napkin rise class and we're here to
share the allotted time the issue with
the cover is actually in your agenda on
page 22 and David I know made reference
to it just now it's the buffer between
the new development and napkin ryan
stratis book and we referred to the
buffer between the existing houses and
the developments on the western boundary
this buffer was proposed from the outset
and was agreed in the outline planning
application that achieved approval in
April of 2016
it's been a matter of some discussion
but always remained until a recent
amendments and this planning application
removed it and awarded it to the in
addition to the long Gardens of the
houses of the new development the
warning the bufferton new houses was
rejected however in a pre planning
meeting in April of last year
and was deemed too difficult to manage
and is covered in the design and access
payment that was produced in support of
the application the applicant has stated
to us in writing that the current meter
high hedgerow that separates the
existing houses from the development
will be at the bottom of the gardens of
the new houses this hedgerow was a
suitable boundary to the agricultural
field that existed but he's totally
unsuitable as a boundary between houses
it will mean a total loss of privacy
between the two sets of houses a
security issue between the properties
and raises the issue we've got in the
ten seconds this well-established
hedgerow and will inevitably result in
disputes between the two sets of houses
we believe a far better solution would
be either retain the buffer as was
originally designed with significant
security to end or put a fence at the
bottom of the lawn gardens of the new
houses and award the buffer to the
existing houses that about the
development we request the committee to
give this serious issue their further
consideration taking miss Peter you have
one minute remaining I'm just wondering
feel White's arrived apologies I'm very
sorry you can still contempt carry on
yeah okay go for it that case you you've
got just over a minute left
I understand the truck it's pretty
horrendous tonight okay I'm afraid miss
kripp she's only got just over a minute
left apologies for that over to you
since the houses were built 21 years ago
previous and current residents of
maintained the boundary edge on both
sides religiously some of these hedges
of an excess of 90 foot long which will
result in some of the existing residents
sharing their cage with approximately
two and a half gardens of the new houses
not only could this mean that the hedge
could potentially be at least three
different heights but also more
worryingly the maintenance of the hedge
could become an uncapped wilderness with
no single point of person or contact in
a dispute what we proposed today is a
solution that will keep the peace with
both existing and future residents so we
ask you to please consider either
retaining the buffer which it can also
called a gap at the edge at the end of
the gardens was the significant
significant security at each end
as agreed on the previous plans or award
the buffer to the existing residents
that are adjacent to the new development
but
existing houses placing necessary
restrictions and regulations to the
maintenance of the buffer of the gap we
request that you give this statement
serious consideration as this will
affect not only the future residents of
this development but also the existing
residents the long-standing residents of
reasonably close and not term rise thank
you very much brilliant any questions
from the committee please yes cats brain
doesn't matter Lancers it really in your
written submission you talk about
football pitches and sports pitches as
you can't separate I think that may have
been the parish council any further
questions cancer bonds where we are so
we could have two or three houses yes
counselor fielding what sort of fence
are you thinking of between the if you
were to be in charge of it doctor thinks
it's a hedge it's a Hawthorne hitch both
sides has been for 21 years but now that
they're talking about having their
gardens extended and the new owners
would would deal with the other side of
the hedge I think two meter high hedge
they have to just look into one
another's gardens what we're proposing
is that the long gardens that were
originally specified in the poem be
fenced and the the land that either be
retained as a buffer like it was before
blocked off at each end to aid security
or give that buffer to the existing
houses and they can then maintain that
that area
okay yes what you're saying you you
wanted to reign as a buffer falling for
you can I come in if that's okay I think
if can't really if you look at the
screen now that that green hedging
through the middle is the case the
buffer that's being proposed it's
already there as well
am I correct in saying come in and just
to clarify this point I know a bit out
of sync but let's just do that yeah
absolutely
the hedge does exist at the moment in
part the photo earlier in my
presentation showed that there are areas
towards rains book close down here where
it would need to be improved I have
included in the update sheet a condition
which would intend to specifically
achieve details of that and triggers for
that so that it could be delivered
promptly and maintained for the duration
okay sorry that the proposal is to
improve the hedge planting on the
immediate boundary and then there are
heavy heavy stock trees to be planted
towards the rear of the gardens and they
would be within the garden areas of
these properties
has managed to join that's exactly of
course you can't take part in the any
part of discussion tonight for this
application or vote as long as you're
aware of that okay if I could go to our
next speakers then these the Katherine
young please and then I've got a list of
other people if you all want to come up
that's fine and take a seat Brno
Katherine Neil could be the one doing
the speaking okay I think everybody else
has just coming up for possible
questions thank you you have six minutes
between you and if you remain seated for
any questions at the end that'd be
fantastic and I'll give you a warning at
ten seconds before the end of your
allotted time if that's okay that case
over to you thank you chair good evening
chair and members of the committee my
name is Katherine and I represent the
applicant Taylor Wimpey Midlands you
have before you a reserved matters
planning application for 535 new homes
that saram it is recognized in planning
policy that Sodom is a sustainable
location for housing growth the site
benefits from allocation for residential
development through policy essay III of
the adopted stratford-on-avon core
strategy her climb planning permission
was granted in December 2016
this application represents phase two of
the development with phase one relating
to initial road and sewer infrastructure
having been approved by delegated
authority on the first of December 2017
the site is identified in the council's
high as in trajectory and is a key
contributor to the council's housing
land supply the application is
recommended for approval by your
office's approve a proposal that
reflects the culmination of proactive
from cooperative discussions between
Taylor Wimpey your offices and other key
stakeholders Taylor Wimpey has met with
southern Town Council on a number of
occasions during the evolution the
proposals and has also provided
personalized responses to concerns
raised by local residents and held
meeting the residents neighboring of
western and southern site boundaries we
have worked with your officer team to
develop a scheme in order to live a high
quality sustainable development which
will provide a real social economic and
environmental benefits for the local
community the proposals have been
revised to directly address concerns
initially raised by local residents this
includes amendments the landscape buffer
on the west and site boundary which is
now included within the Gardens of the
proposed dwellings to ensure that any
potential for anti-social behavior isn't
removed this was discussed and agreed
with the Town Council as the most
appropriate design Taylor Wimpey is keen
to ensure or keen to continue to build
on existing relationships formed with
the Terran Council and local residents
and is committed to establishing a
stakeholder group in order that all
interested parties can remain up-to-date
regarding the progress of the site
through the entire build period all
technical matters have been fully
resolved and your officer has confirmed
in their report that the proposals
represent a high quality design and at
the range of house types and materials
proposed ensures visual interest Taylor
Wimpey has worked closely with the local
highway authority who have confirmed
they have no objection to their
proposals the officers confirmed the
proposal achieves a government's aims
set out in the MPP F of promoting mixed
communities and response from material
considerations specific to asylum given
the clear benefits of the proposals and
the officers clear recommendation we
respectfully request that player finish
is granted for the proposed development
and finally thank you for the
opportunity to address committee this
evening thank you very much any
questions please yes counselor fielding
at the parking and garage is not being
taken into account or my being a bit
premature no bum parking and am
garrotting has been taken into account
the parking guidelines pre-buy camera at
the other day are at the moment limited
weights there's a lot of consultation to
go through first counselor so at the
moment the members should really
consider that as limited weight at the
moment okay counselor Mills
I thought you indicated the questions
now O'Donnell sorry good evening
um just a quick question regarding the
boundary because obviously that what
seems to be causing and some concern to
the current residents how about have
been part of that the new properties
Gardens potentially reduce antisocial
behavior is that I believe that's what
you were saying yes so that the the
proposed buffer will now have form part
of the garden for the proposed dwellings
through initial discussions there the
first layout showed a buffer not to be
in the garden neither the existing
properties on that tune rise or range
but close all the proposed properties
concerns were raised then that due to
the sort of wide nature this open piece
of land or although was proposed to be
secured there is concern that people
could still access that area it will now
be within the private property of the
proposed dwellings it's not new notice
that this has been part of the
discussions through the determination of
the application and plan has met with
those residents and the Town Council and
through those discussions it was decided
it was the most appropriate
and suitable design for this part of the
scheme no further questions thank you
very much what with you we can move to
on it thank you okay we can go two
points no one go to our ward member
councillor Crump so thank you return
thank you welcome councillor Crump say
you know the routine you've got five
minutes over to you all right
the 555 houses were our key part of the
five-year housing nan supply and the
core strategy and although when this
site was originally first put in the
core strategy object is strongly and
we'll actually voted on the core
strategy was one of nine you actually
voted against this proposal because I
thought it was too many houses for sale
been in mine will have him including a
535 via them at 100 houses but I'll know
accepted is is taken place but it's
important to make sure we get the
infrastructure right as well as the
housing mix for local needs is now
pleasing to hear that the developers
found a social housing provider to take
this scheme on board and work has been
undertaken to ensure there is the
correct mix of houses that meets a local
needs as you've probably heard much work
has been undertaken to RNA many of the
issues that have arisen and they have
been resolved as you can see from the
update sheet and also from the
withdrawal of the objection from the
Town Council there are still one or two
issues there I'll talk about in a minute
but the one real issue that you've
already heard about is regarding the
heads and the boundary
and obviously the neighbors have got
this concern I think you know on I can
see both sides of the argument on this
one and I think I will leave it to the
committee to make the appropriate
decision on this matter and so I can see
from the neighbors point of view but I
can also see the issue regarding
anti-social behaviour so I think it's
probably further that you was outside
away from the Parliament away from the
area can make a decision that can be
seen as fair and neutral the tank answer
obviously is mind it's concerns known
about the vehicle tracking and regarding
the H TVs and delivery vehicles and
refuse vehicles around the metallic
spices and some of those I don't
necessarily disagree with but the
countess a County Council again have
said this is not unusual and again it's
been mentioned in the update sheet that
they are willing to accept accept the
advice from the Highways Authority one
positive point tonight is that portfolio
order has agreed that there will be a
liaison group between the district
casters per se thumb the developer the
contract social housing provided
potentially local residents and SEC
officers so we can hopefully improve
communications and quickly on and after
any issues that arise and again the
developers listen to my one of my major
concerns regarding the underpass which
is going to be one of the key routes
into the town which can sort of from
extreme flooding at times you can
actually it goes right up to the ceiling
it's also been anti-social behavior in
that area and lighting and flooding and
CCTV issues have all been mentioned in
the update sheets off again that's the
positive outcome so apart from the hydro
issue which I remain neutral on are now
support the proposal and hope the
developer can have a long-term and
positive relationship at the time
thank you Thank You counselor any
questions for the ward member counselor
bonds in my speech I can see both sides
to it and obviously I'm on the 10
counselor as well but I do stand apart
from that part of the for the meeting
and I've been contacted by by night this
to to the site who obviously have
objected and then have also been
contacted by other neighbors who think
it's a good idea
so to be fair to both my first sets of
constituents off awful it's Thank You
cancer bones I remember that for future
reference there any year further
questions councillor O'Donnell good
evening and care check has the subject
of broadband then addressed yet given
SNP 535 analysis and the issues we all
face are different Ward's with and
broadband issues I could touch that with
my count accounts that have done and
there is going to be some money put
aside for fiber-optic because the be
Southam not too bad for a broadband
point of view but as you get to towards
an optimum this is on the left and Road
it just starts to taper off and when you
get tuned up tuned it's very poor so yes
is on one of my priorities to make sure
it just happen but I can't see that
being a particularly rare issue for that
site so if there no further questions
councillor Crump thank you very much
right should we go to points of
clarification does anybody here have any
questions I'd like to ask the officers
callously fielding I am concerned about
the legal problems whose boundary
disputes was probably one of the most
aggravating things one has to deal with
and I would like to make sure that the
officers
in in what they're sorry I'm probably
getting into debate rather than into a
question here but make sure that the
officers do create a proper boundary
that can be maintained both sides rather
than just have the buffer because the
buffer will create antisocial problems
and I think that you know I'd like to
hear what the officers are going to just
confirm again just to clarify just where
this is what the situation is with that
buffer one more time for us so the
situation with the buffer is that it
would be part of the garden of the
properties within the development site
there is an existing hedge and that
would be improved but in terms of the
size of these Gardens they are very
substantial now that they've
incorporated that area of land so I
think on average you would be looking at
around an 18 meter area between the rear
of those elevations and the boundary so
a portion of that in between the garden
and the hedge would be planted with a
stock of trees and native shrubs we have
proposed in the update sheet that that
would be secured by condition and that
would be a condition which would see
replanting of any unsuccessful plants
there for the period of the development
up to five years so we would expect that
to be well established by the time
Taylor Wimpey leave the site I think
could address equal well whose
responsibility is it to maintain they
would be within those garden areas so
there would be the owners of those
properties would be responsible for the
maintenance of the buffer they had taken
ownership would they be in any way
compelled to maintain the buffer we
would have a condition that could be
enforced against those future owners if
they were to remove substantial elements
of it is it still on the buffer question
counts of Hilda Conley the curse of
hedges is that needs to be clipped
both sides so you're going to have to
have some sort of right of access from
the wherever that hedges to get around
to the other side to deal with it I'm
not convinced that's really a planning
matter as much as it is property matter
really know how to come later
I've got councillor hours next thing
councillor I appreciate the age I had
did outgoing overlooked and it is being
maintained by the houses on the one side
it looks to me and I'm correct is that
the builders don't give grafted down and
put all the freezing and then leave it
to the occupants to look after it is
that instead of the company doing it in
in essence once they had planted it and
sold the properties that would be it yes
from Taylor Wimpey it would be the
owners it wouldn't necessarily go to a
company the intention here is that it
would be the town council be offered for
the open space first thank you can I ask
so with with the hedge row in the bath
and the buffer with the existing
developments and properties does that
buffer is that at the end of their
gardens so will this have if if the
hedges aren't maintained effectively
without to have an impact on their view
and what they're seen from their gardens
and will it impact on them the the hedge
forms the boundary of their garden at
the current time that wouldn't change
calm down
Thank You Gemini I wonder if I can put
this in context to perhaps help members
to visualize what's happening here the
proposal is to build a row of new houses
next to a boundary under normal
circumstances we'd be looking at a
rather new houses a garden an existing
boundary and then the existing
properties at an early stage in this
application and looking at David to
confirm this to me there was a proposal
that a buffer be created here in order
to provide the existing residents with a
higher standard of amenity a higher
standard of privacy than would normally
be provided and the original intention
David was that that buffer would not
belong to either set of house holders
the parish council Town Council I
apologize were concerned that they would
be expected to adopt it that whoever was
responsible for it it would become a
magnet for anti-social behavior so
negotiations between the negotiations
let me not specify who negotiations
resulted in that changing so that the
buffer is owned by a house holder the
house holders have responsible for
bility for it and there is no reason to
think that that will cause antisocial
behavior so that's completely addressed
the anti-social behavior issue there
remains the issue of the relationship
with the adjoining properties and the
distance between them and David has
explained that the gardens on average
for this property are about for this
these properties are about 18 metres
long which is about 8 meters longer than
a garden would normally be so you have
extra-long gardens with an area of
planting at the bottom which it is
expected that the householders will
continue to maintain and there will be a
condition requiring that at least for
five years thank you yes Council are
correct in saying that this has been
done because the Town Council and
because of consultation I would have
suppose this the changes come about
through consultation with the Town
Council
yeah okay so just came back um Dale
thank to the explanation can I just
check why is it lemurs just five years
that they're expected to maintain the
hedges it's it's a standard time period
five years in the past yeah it's a
standard time period in the past
councils have tried to impose longer
maintenance periods which has not been
sort of supported by inspectors so the
five year period has now become a
standard nationwide it would be jolly
difficult to try to enforce a condition
beyond that right there are further
points of clarification should we go to
the debate so you'd like to start
councillor brain then council balance
you beat you just I try not to sit on
the fence chairman what I've heard has
been negotiations with the Tang Council
the ward member seems to be happy now
and I think we've got a better decision
with the the boundary fence
it takes away they under social behavior
and I'm happy to move the recommendation
on page 28 that we approve the
recommendation okay so we've got a
proposal does anybody want to jump
straight to a second only too happy to
secondly but I'm very pleased about is
there is a liaison committee which i
think is essential which does work well
any problems with hedges and that sort
of thing can be addressed and i'm
crappity go to the vote that was a
fullness second thing of that proposal
councillor fielding then counselor
O'Donnell
countless Rodon thank you seeing back to
my previous point when when does a
condition regarding broadband come into
play because but from recent discussions
in within group it's been about the fact
that we need to really emphasize that
broadband is as important as the utility
to people and to say this an amount that
will be left aside it's not specific
enough really when it's gonna be five
over five hundred new properties more
point clarification but you last down
what you think of strengthening the the
condition of broadband provision mmm-hmm
anyway that can be done you'll have
guessed from the hesitation chair I'm
struggling with this one can I keep can
I turn this round on members and ask
them what strengthening they think would
be helpful and then I can perhaps give a
a planning assessment of whether we can
achieve that I'm not quite clear what
members are trying to achieve I suppose
is the answer I'm giving I mean where is
it stating what's going to happen unless
I've missed it regarding the not only
broadband is it listed there David which
point should be looking at where yeah I
have I have received details with this
reserve matters of broadband proposals
and they do commit to delivering fast
fibre broadband to the site discuss that
with the applicant and I have no doubt
that they will deliver that I'm not sure
there's a condition on the outline
approval at this time that says when
that will be triggered I'd imagine that
it's upon occupation effectively because
we've received details relating to that
as part of this reserve matters it would
perhaps not be inappropriate to
condition those details that have been
received as part of any approval here
council fielding
out of our discussions last night there
was an indication from fellow councilor
who deals very much in the computer
world that there is a there are other
forms coming forward that will improve
the broadband facility wireless etc so
you know it may not be that fiber is
around at that or is old hat by the time
this is developed so I think we've got
to make sure that speeds are maintained
but depends on the technology at the
time yes okay is ABS want to speak in
the debate well we have a proposition
that has been seconded that we approve
the application should we go to the vote
all those pleas in favor of approving
stands the show
therefore the committee resolves to
grant application reference 17 / 0 1 9 3
0 / REM we can move to item 6 on
tonight's agenda
our next application
okay next up we've got item six and this
is found on page 43 of the agendas and
this is application reference 17 / 0 1 4
- 9 / REM is land off the burros new
board on style and it's reserved matters
pursuant to the outline permission
previously for the construction of up to
35 dwellings that were granted an appeal
presenting officer Hedy wrench Eddie
over to you
Thank You chair the application site is
located at the southern edge of the
village of newbould on star
at the junction of Mill Lane and a3 400
Stratford Road and denoted here by the
black dot access to the site is from the
Burroughs to the north western edge
which was which was approved at outline
stage the site here is outlined in red
as shown this is an aerial view of the
site showing the surrounding residential
development to the northeast and
northwest and other agricultural areas
surrounding the site is currently scrub
London trees with some derelict
buildings this is the proposed site plan
showing the 35 dwellings which
recombination of 12 affordable units in
23 open market units as part of the
proposal 82 off street car parking
spaces would be provided as well as 18
garage spaces barring the initial part
of the access into the site the roads
and foot ways within the site would be
unadopted and maintained by a management
company this slide shows the proposed
site is superimposed onto the aerial
view the existing boundary hedges are
all proposed to be retained thinned and
gapped up where necessary this light
shows two of the proposed street scenes
within the development with some of the
house type shown
this photo is from the Burroughs looking
towards the approved accessing to the
site here is a short video from within
the site showing the access to the
dwellings the existing dwellings along
the Burroughs and miles Meadows in the
written the background here and some of
the existing vegetation on the site some
of the fencing shown was is a the
low-level fencing shown is for
ecological purposes which is being
agreed with the County Council this next
video is also taken within the site
further in the southern portion and it
shows the a 3 400 in the background and
just beyond these trees here some of the
internal trees and scrubland which would
be removed to make way for the houses
and also some of the derelict buildings
finally this photo is looking northwards
along Stratford Road with the
application sight to the right hand side
beyond the mature boundary vegetation
there is one update with a
representation from WCC ecology of no
objection chairman the recommendation is
to grant permission subject to the
conditions and notes detailed on pages
51 to 53 of the agenda
thank you thank you Eddie okay our first
speaker on this application and is there
counselor Paul Clayton from trading
temporis counsel please welcome
counselor so you have three minutes if
you'd remain seated for any questions at
the end and I'll give you a warning at
the final ten seconds if that's okay if
you press the bottom in the middle as
well as perfect thank you over to you
good evening and to start with I'd like
to bring up the parking issues to
maximize the density of the housing
development only incorporate single
garages per house single garages perhaps
with parking for any of the vehicles
outside due to the layout this would
require vehicles to reverse into
neighbors boundaries to exit or reverse
all the way to the road due to the
nature of the rural location the limited
public transport kyu's is heavy and most
residents have owned at least two cars
some properties don't have parking next
to the property which will lead to
vehicle was being left on highway the
revised parking layout has 84 spaces
however it would appear that six have
been given to one haps four to another
and seven of the two three-bedroom homes
have been allocated three parking spaces
sorry three parking space H all are
behind one another there is no space for
street parking so the additional 13
spaces should not really kept putting
cars parking behind one another is not
really very practical as it would
inevitably lead to the need
for swap places and certainly one car
been left on the road to allow the first
to exit the plan is now answer to the
shortage of parking spaces and also
bungalows there are no bungalows which
are needed appeared to be included in
the housing type this would mean that
the mix is not backed by the shi Mei
which is being a requirement of other
recent developments in new bolt-on right
safety ro safety audit has raised three
concerns including pedestrian safety and
restricted visibility for reversing cars
which have not been addressed in the
ecology side of things there is no
detail or mention of the wildlife
corridor one of the conditions of the
exempt ins put by the planning officers
is that the development should take
certain steps to preserve any wildlife
there this is also stated in the ecology
mitigation an enhancement scheme report
it would appear from recent observations
that they are just plowing through the
land regardless now the ecology
migration and enhancement scheme depends
on a new wildflower meadow however there
is no mention of a legal obligation to
maintain it and now established time
period who will be responsible for its
maintenance long term will there be
access for the public we fear that it
will just end up looking like a message
growth are not compensate for the loss
of the wildlife and environment on the
play area in seconds who is going to
maintain it appears to be designed
solely for small children and it's very
little green space within development
apart from this there's also no verges
which does not blend sympathetically
sorry I'm afraid any questions please
for the parish council council apari
good evening can you perhaps
Rhys do you have a neighborhood plan at
all or are you in the process we are in
the process of providing okay and if I
may ask a supplementary chair this the
design of this is our other typical
developments in u-bolts instead of that
have similar parking arrangements
well the the estate next door was built
a few years ago and that has much better
access for parking and much better
verges etc so it is a lot less cramped
and more in keeping with all the
developments whereas this there is no
real green verge space it's a lot more
cramped from from the view above doesn't
really show it that well but the parking
is an issue they just seem to have
crammed as many houses as possible even
without taking into account people
getting around the road also the road
itself is so narrow that you maybe don't
lightly away from whether question thank
you
councillor fielding the entrance to the
site comes off the borough's of the main
road through the boroughs is that Road
wide enough particularly just before you
get to the Hammerhead that will then
become the entrance onto the new site
it looks very cramped well yes no so the
main route through is going to be an
adopted so where are all the bins going
to go well I understand the county
haven't raised any objection so we'll
have to move on from that point counts
the mill and councillor crapola just
just very quickly what any consultation
with the Parish Council with the
developer on this one very little but it
was and with their correspondence
unfortunately I'm not in a position to
say exactly cuz it's not something
closed out with a pintle racing on this
particular application I'm afraid so
there was going back to my colleagues to
to done some would say I'm actually not
sure so
okay okay cats like rubber just
concerned about our home for the houses
comparing character and street scene
compared to houses nearby they are more
cramped together they have the
appearance is more cramped there's less
green space the visible appearance of
the properties is going to be more krump
than anything else in the area right if
there are no further questions okay
councillor Clayton thank you very much
we go now to jillian Marsden please
speak on behalf the residents welcome
sir you also have three if you'd remain
seated for any questions at the end
again I'll give you a warning at final
ten seconds if that's okay
over to you I live in New Orleans tower
in miles measure new build is a rural
dark sky village there's been no
communication with the village all the
residents in respect of the design or of
this application I believe actually this
is a breach of the NPP F when blow homes
originally obtained the planning consent
it was for up to 35 houses and they were
relying on the land aged blue which they
treated in their application as learn to
be cultivated to link the habitat with a
wildlife corridor and to provide green
space this project was dropped before
the appeal the blue area is not actually
included in the current planning
application this development is lacks
green space and further that the
wildlife corridor has been totally
ignored and not included which was a
conditionally appeal new brought is a
rural village almost all the lanes
within the village have green verges and
small green areas especially in the sand
field estate this is an urban style
development which will be a poor
relation tacked on to the end of the
Burroughs there's a large quantity of
two bedroom houses the village is
actually short a three-bedroom to buy
all
and there is a demand for smaller
bungalows for elderly and disabled the
parking design is a disgrace of putting
all these extra parking spaces into
private properties doesn't help there's
no available parking for visitors and
the reality will be cars will be parked
all over the place and on the pavements
it also lead to disputes with the land
ownership even more so with the
unadopted drives feeding a number of the
houses the sand-filled estate has
insufficient parking at present
residents and visitors already have to
park on the road or even the pavement
additional traffic through here will not
be sustainable bearing in mind there
will be no room for construction workers
to park all construction traffic there
is only one way for vehicles and
pedestrians to access the village and
that is through the narrow double bends
of the borough's which would endanger
pedestrians I'm concerned about the
proposal to maintain the land by John
Bradley it raises the question what
happens when he's incapable or dies and
will it be open to the public to enjoy I
conceived the born flowers being planted
just being grazed by deer and it won't
be an enhancement in conclusion the
planning was given for up to 35 houses
this does not mean 35 houses must be
built new build has already exceeded the
call strategy figure this site does not
include the make up of houses needed and
the parking is grossly inadequate 10
seconds this urban style development is
just so out of character with the rest
of the village and it will not burn
didn't the sand fill estate and nor does
it echo the Mansell farmer stage which
is currently under construction thank
you perfect timing thank you any
questions please from the committee No
in that case thank you very much for
your time we now get our board member
councillor st.
welcome council sight okay so you also
have five minutes I think you know the
routine from now so hope you thank you
chairman I think you hit the nail on the
head when you announced or somebody on
the top table announced that the outline
application here was granted on appeal
there's been a lot of contention over
this site and it's been long resisted by
a development on this land has been long
resisted because it doesn't sit
naturally within the village it extends
it
however the Planning Inspectorate has
granted the principle of development on
this site so I won't argue against that
although I'm arguing that this scheme
should not be approved one of the main
issues is been dealt with but can I
argue can't remove you chairman because
I'm sure you were in that chair when the
outline planning permission was refused
by the committee and that is we had an
arrangement by which there was an over
intensity of houses on this site the up
to 35 because there was a contrived
scheme to include a bit of land down the
road as part of the open space
requirement and I see absolutely no
reference to that in the officer's
report nor do I see any reference to the
issue of whether or not the estate the
proposed estate complies with the manual
for streets right which is our problem
to sort out I've had this discussion mr.
barker on several occasions and
effectively it relies on the facilities
to get the refuse vehicles into this
site however the main problem so those
are deficiencies in my view in the
officers report which I think at least a
worthy of a explanation or even a
deferral but the main problem I find is
the announcement from
syringe was an 83 car parking spaces he
announced if I've got the number wrong I
apologize it was a hell of a lot to fit
in where where are these vast numbers of
parking spaces going to exist we're
going to rely on cars because there's
not much of a bus service in u-bolt
therefore we have to make certain I
personally think that this scheme should
be rejected and the developer has an
opportunity to come back to actually put
a bit more space in I think as mr.
Clayton decided to say the development
here is far more intensive than other
things around it in answer to councilor
Crump's question I can answer councillor
Parrish question about the question of
whether or not the developer consulted
the Parrish I don't have any record of
it and I'm usually engaging with these
things so they've come along this cold
and not necessarily taking into account
the views okay we've got to have some
houses here but this is far too
intensive we're gonna need off street
car parking or even on street car
parking within the development because
of the lousy bus services
so therefore the scale of development
the scale of the proposals is far too
great and on those grounds
I urge you to reject it Thank You
Council thank any questions for the ward
member please council bonds 80 sites
well perhaps come yes the white parts
are the parking areas yes we can come
back and clarify later any other
questions
council saying thank you very much right
that's good point of clarification we've
had our first one already yes
the white air is on the representation
in front of you other other allocated
parking spaces
counts the brain to know the width of
the estate Road where vehicles would
have to reverse 8 we're told I assume
there's a footpath as well there's a
footpath on either side of the road and
I believe the road is a 5 meter with the
cars could pass on the road without
having to pull in or anything like that
yeah the width has been accepted tires
also being tracked from Refuge lorry and
large delivery lorries to show they can
go round the site looks like it it has
an additional footpath as well as the
road to me it has both sides and then
the curb to curb is still 5 meters so
there's a width of the road on which
cars will travel yeah it's five meters
of them as an additional yes counselor
millisecond so Crump
thanks mr. Jim on clarification is there
only one way in one way out on this I
can see at the moment what about the
construction it traffic will that be
just one way in and one way out there's
no other way in or out the access has
approved for the for the development so
the future residents would approve the
outline and that is through the burrows
right there is a current access onto
Mill Lane as well which has been opened
up for some of the ecology work and it's
my understanding that potentially that
could be used as well if there was any
issues on this question of parking
is it is it too bad well because we in
sold by Councillor plate and it was a
four-on-three and - it's at least 2 per
dwelling and there's also additional as
well on some so it's a minimum of 2 for
every dwelling with with quite several
with more than that a minimum [ __ ] okay
so all had okay can I just get a bit
sorry Eddie if we come back to the
second road you said that if you used
for ecology you just go back on those
comments again I'm not quite following
you the previous comments so the
question was about the access in terms
of the second road you said
okay and with that obviously won't
remain in the final development sorry
that isn't part of the final development
that I'm thinking of trying to reduce
construction traffic's with the
Burroughs it could be right okay maybe
that's helpful to our question I'm going
to run through the questions in which
they've been saying this account sir
Crump then I'll come down here yeah a
couple things Eddie please post four to
seven ecology budgets anything in the
conditions about that does anything
being proposed in terms of ecology yep
all the ecological conditions were
originally attached to the outline
permission
they've also they've all been agreed now
with the count ecologist and signed off
and there's they have not recommended
any further ecological conditions yeah
so I just wonder why you mentioned
enhance wildlife collars or cuz I
thought if it had been engraved in the
out the original outline why does it
want it enhanced can you clarify that
question for me I'm not sure that I
understood it I don't know about Eddie
but I didn't well I meant to say sorry I
missed page 47
okay are we able to school in enhanced
wildlife corridor across along the
Northeast uncommon site plan reflect the
recommendation for budget advised in
their survey so was that agreed in the
original act like plan so because from
what you've told me it's those
conditions to the apply so if they do
apply and those conditions are in there
why do we need to put that part in the
report that comment is obviously come
from County ecology based
the Cotswolds wildlife ecology cool work
that's been done went on site following
further discussions following these
comments in the update sheets the
mitigation measures which detail by the
applicants ecologist
were satisfactory covered those points
and he was happy with it after that
include the corridor as well
it says about party mitigation
he was happy that the existing plans and
the additional ecological plans that
were submitted covered those points okay
that's fine and the point I got relates
to the open space I believe and I've
mentioned it was part of the appeal
something about open space and it's not
been addressed could you just clarify
that so wouldn't exactly hundred isn't
sure about that night I should have
asked answer the site about that really
in respect to the outline it was
previously included that you can just
see it on the corner here that there
would be another contribution of the
line within the applicants ownership
during the appeal there wasn't any
conditions attached to that and that
actually doesn't form part of this
application or the outline so everything
on the site would be formed by what is
shown just within the red line all right
so now got councillor Barnes and council
fielding yes it does appear that the
site is being used to another entrance
other than going through the houses can
we put a condition that the construction
he's done through that site I think we
referred to the middle lane access and
we're happy that we can condition that
satisfy counts the fielding going back
on to what counsel vans are saying Mill
Lane is very narrow and I would have
thought that there there isn't that
width for turning circles etc into the
site but my other point is use of public
transport anybody who wants to use
public transports but along I will walk
all the way through the boroughs to it
if they're going to be any form of sort
of path pedestrian gate off the site to
allow people to catch passes if if
there's a bus stop in the near vicinity
no the only access of pedestrians will
be through the borough's okay all right
any other points of clarification
councillor brain I just want to come
back on the the parking issue if I may
that's it yeah looking at top right and
it looks like a shared driveway between
two houses so I wonder if sufficient
distance between the two driveways
so that's a shared driveway between two
houses yeah so what's the width of that
and this is a room to open a car door
with other cars there there's a second
part of the question which are asked in
a minute all the widths of the driveways
and parking spaces have been assessed in
terms of the stamps put forward by
County highways and they were satisfied
that they met their minimum requirements
for parking sizes parking in terms of
size as you can see here they've been
mapped out for each individual space two
spaces for any dwelling does that
include the garage because we know that
on on occasion garages are users stores
not parking areas yeah so to clarify
numbers there is between the 35
dwellings there's 82 allocated spaces
and 18 additional garage spaces so all
in all there's technically a hundred
spaces off the road just to put that in
put some perspective in terms of the
endorsed standards cabinets the same
amount would have been 475 dwellings and
fourteen visitor spaces which would have
been 89 right if we can work out the
precise width of the don't think I have
the width unfortunately
we've got this come up before return
plan application where the two [ __ ]
couldn't open the doors so I think it's
important that we know that candy house
allowance agreed with still in points of
clarification so I suppose counts a
brain you within your rights to ask of
course it doesn't necessarily form some
objective to question what officers and
consult into that desire absolutely fine
you asking a question that's okay we can
just wait for an answer if possible
right we've got a scale rule if we just
take a two-minute break just literally
swim to get the right ruler so we can
measure and they would get an answer to
your question
two minutes only don't go far
thank you right okay we're back and
we've got some answers so Eddie over to
you
Thank You chair sorry for the delay as
shown here the width of the box from
here to here is 2.5 meters by four point
seven meters and depth and the distance
from the actual center point of the
drive to the outside of the drive is
three meters and the average width of
the car average width of the car is
about 1.8 meters so that just to confirm
it does allow the car doors to open
even if everyone's parked there at the
same time for a normal vehicle yes
average vehicle okay
can I makes it you've got a question I
think there's we were just mentioning
about we can't deal with that now
importance of clarification because it's
one that's come up and we were talking
about Mill Lane and access for
construction traffic I think I'm right
in saying or is it possible the
inspectors decision said that couldn't
be used for any sort of construction
traffic or any sort of traffic is in
terms of an access okay what whoever
wants to update it on that which I want
to check because I was about to ask for
a condition
what my question was and I think counsel
about sort of supporting I was sort of
moving along the lines of maybe we could
offer construct a construction traffic
route through Mill Lane rather than
inconveniencing the residents of the
borough's but it appears it possible
that the inspector who approved the
outline application said that that
access could not be used so we just need
to confirm that before we can put any
condition about anything else all right
so we're just confirming it
okay I'm gonna ask you to confirm that
right so on that issue of site access
because it's something I've raised and
that's the fielding you sort of talked
about it and so did you counterbalance I
think if we could my view at this point
is if it could be conditioned that site
access be from Mill Lane to aid in the
construction process to reduce any sort
of problem for the residents I would
prefer that and I think that's
definitely the way I'd want to go with
it however we're not able at this point
in time to confirm that what commit
committees views do you share my my
thoughts that actually that's really
critical and I would like to see that if
it's at all possible if that is the case
then we would probably have to look at
deferring this in order to get proper
information on whether or not we could
use the Mill Lane access for
construction use only not the permanent
use but for construction use only counts
the brain first strong condition on
timings and okay right counsel I'm sorry
I think we can just put a note on to ask
the the applicant if we can use middle
lane or in the construction I really
would prefer to make sure we know this
and chaps do you feel at this point you
can give us a clear answer on that
to be clear we haven't found anything
within the original outline permission
there is a condition 18 I believe for a
construction management plan for details
of that so as part of that they could
explore the possibility of using Mill
Lane to access the site for any reason
they can't do that
then it would have to be through the
Burroughs but there is a condition
already attached that we would have to
agree conditions of right because
structural Management Council Mills so
mister on that point did the inspector
say mu Lane so you did inspect say my
lane can't be used do you say that we on
the appeal we can't find and I think I
wasn't at the
earing so I don't know why he was
verbally said Bitzer knee not work what
we can't find it within his decision
notice well if we can't find it in there
then we can we can condition it am I
correct we could then a condition it's
based on your can based on your reading
yes
subject to agreement with County
highways obviously saying that it's safe
access okay okay sorry I'm aware that
we're still in points of clarification I
know we're diverging slightly any other
points of clarification before we go to
a debate right let's go to debate then
what do we think councillor Perry then
I'll move down here well I'm actually
got some serious concerns about this
particular application as I feel it
there are three pots get call strategy
policies which to me I'll have a bit of
an issue with I have an issue with cs9
which is design and distinctiveness
because this is highlighted by the local
resident and also the ward member in
terms of it doesn't fit in with the
locality and I think it falls down onto
the s9 I think it also falls down on CS
19 which is housing mix in tight we've
already had identified this evening that
the mix of dwellings do not reflect
local need I also feel it falls down on
CS 15 as well so I've been interested to
hear what others other members say I've
got two councillor fielding them brain
then I move on to this side again house
he makes in my view is not suitable to
really to look towards bungalows and
single units because people are going to
want to downsize and I think this is a
an area which can is suitable for that
sort of activity to happen also the fact
is that I think there's too many four
houses on the site or buildings
properties on the site we've got that
they tracked through the borough's which
is not going to be convenient
for the existing residents so I think
the less weak properties we can put on
the site and more suitable properties
for people the better counselor brain
yes German I tend to agree with my
colleagues on our made a note for layout
and design of parking garages brought
about by over intensive building density
I've never liked tandem parking and
having to reverse eight onto state roads
and if the garage is not used as a
parking area it makes it even more
difficult so I will go against the
officers recommendation afraid yes
counselor Donna sorry thank you and I
agree with what my fellow councillors
have said and also I think it just feels
as if they've come along and popped a
development in rather than listening to
what the locals want to need it's not
the right housing mix for the area
parking is always a contentious issue on
whatever development on your parking
behind each other it's just going to get
worse for someone slightly out of line
and also it does concern there's been no
real engagement between the developers
because they had engaged I've known what
than what the area actually need it and
there's not the correct mix of houses
and it just it seems to me like an over
development which has been said and I
think as the ward member suggested
perhaps they should go away really
redesign and come back with a different
application council mills yes Monsieur I
think it will be in citizen if I am my
beef would be that it is just over
developed for the site and that I think
that that's what happened while we
turned it down in the first place before
we went to appeal and yet it's just over
Darrell another site for me
thank you miss Chen so I'll be I'll be
going the officers recommendation thank
you thank you sorry counseling those
council bonds correct too many big asses
not parking if it was thirty five houses
and we've we have
have 35 houses but if they were a
different mix it would be I think more
appropriate so I'm quite happy to
propose refusal on a intensification of
the site Thank You councillor brain this
is for a second okay proposed and
seconded
we're gonna need to flush these reasons
for refused laughter I think Dale's been
taking notes as we go along
councillor Perry I know you've given us
cs9 design styled not fitting CS 19 CS
19 because it's the housing mix and type
which contributes to over development at
the site okay would you care to comment
on the strength of those as well as
reasons refusal on this application just
a point for noting yes thank you
perhaps I can start with thee with CS 15
counts Lipari I said that she felt but
it was contrary to CS 15 because it was
cramped if I understood it correctly CS
15 is talking about distribution of
development within the district and
numbers within the district not within a
particular site so I would suggest that
CS 15 is probably the wrong direction to
go if you're concerned about the cramped
nature councillor Perry also mentioned
CS 9 which is about design and if you
consider that the site is excessively
cramped then I would suggest that it's
probably a poor design and therefore cs9
is the right place to be looking if it's
Krampus that you're concerned about them
housing mix CS 19 yes if you look on
page 50 you'll see that about two-thirds
of the way down we go through the
housing mix
and we explained that the two-bedroom
houses on site comes in at 35 percent
which is bang on the mix the core
strategy is looking for three-bedroom
properties come in at 35 which is low
and four bedroom properties come in at
31 which is high so there is a disparity
there between the threes and the force
we've previously reported to members
that as the housing mix is a target for
the district as a whole we can't expect
developers to hit the numbers bang on
for every site and there does have to be
an element of flexibility from site to
site and in allowing that flexibility we
are expecting the mix to be achieved
over the plan period so that that still
has to be our advice in the past we have
said the variances in threes and fours
on this site are close enough to the mix
in the core strategy - in our opinion
deliver the mix over the plan period
it's not precisely correct it does
amount to a reason profusely if that's
what members wish to do I would suggest
it is a very weak reason for refusal
because of the long plan period and the
large number of sites that you have to
consider when looking at makes I think
I've covered all the points chair did I
miss anything
yes cancer come talk a bit more about
first of all about the mix is it not in
keeping with the neighborhood fund
because we mentioned I think the first
council actually mentioned about all the
parish council mentioned there was no
wonder bedroom properties and I believe
there was I think a neighborhood plan
they were talking about bungalows as
well and I know the price council
neighborhood plan has got limited white
because has been
condemn the right steps and gone to
referendum yet but there's no account of
local need regarding the mix regardin
says 15 and the appearance and the
design we could protect use that for
because it says isn't it the designer
formula houses would reflect the context
the locality ensuring a continuity of
key design features that were
established the identity of the place
and from what the neighborhood plan
sorry what the Parish Council and the
ward member said it was not in keeping
with the locality so I thought that part
of said CS 15 could apply there Adela's
which can you refer to exactly where
you're talking about 49 policy says 15
because the design of the developments
be well related to and can be regularly
integrative it exists inform the
settlement sorry chair it was it was the
reason why I mention CS 15 because under
the requirements he talks about on page
84 the core strategy the scale of the
development is appropriate to its
immediate surroundings and to the
overall size and character the
settlement and the design of the
development is well related to and can
be readily integrated with the existing
form of the settlement I felt the design
and its distinctiveness went against
this policy which is in CS 15 which is
why I mentioned it in in the first part
of the debate and what about a s 10
because it's not in keeping with the
houses around it and therefore it's not
minimizing the impact on the character
the local landscape on page 194 core
strategy
I know holiday this is another education
share where I think I need to ask
counselor O'Donnell to clarify her
thoughts simply because it's different
does that mean it's not minimizing the
impact any in which case why isn't it
minimizing the impact if I understood
you correctly your concern was that this
development is different to the
surrounding development and it's not
meeting the the local needs so it's not
in keeping with that local community
okay does that clarify it or not
sorry saying it's it's it's not in
keeping with this street scene it's out
of character and it's it's not in
keeping with the local character or
meeting the needs the local community I
think we've had enough reasons and I
think officers you've heard our
reasoning you may not be as strong as
you like but I think we'll leave it I
don't think I'll just take lead from the
committee if that's okay
is parking part of your concern in terms
of the poor design I just want to make
sure we're just clarifying in terms of
numbers or in terms of the design tandem
okay time please thank you design poor
design layout and it would like a room
guys please one of the time sorry and we
would like a reference to this that the
parking in the way there the nature of
the parking I think in terms now
dissatisfaction with this one okay so
that's definitely part of it I can nods
okay
Dale jet got it leave it with me thank
you right thank God okay
it's been proposed and seconded I
suggest we go to the vote if you're all
happy with that all those voting to
reject or in respect of the reasons that
we've had mentioned in great detail now
please show the committee resolves to
refuse application reference 17 / 0 1 4
to 9 / REM it's getting late
our final application then is on is item
8 and on page 71 Eddie if you'd like to
whip through this pretty quickly for me
this is application reference 17 / 0 to
6 6 8
could I ask members of the public to
give us just a little bit of quiet so we
can get this finished thank you / ful
and this is for five new ball drove
wells ball over to you Thank You chair
this site is within the center of worlds
bond as shown here by the black dots the
application site is outlined in red as
shown here black sorry the application
site from an aerial view is shown here
with a front green garden this is a view
south along the road showing the
neighboring property to the right the
applications like is the short closed
for defense shown here on the right with
the neighboring property and this is
going north with the application sites
shown on the left with the closed
boarded fence there are no updates
chairman the recommendation is to grant
thank you
just very quickly confirm the reason
this is here at committee the
application is only going to committee
because it is a member of or relation to
a member of the council thank you thank
you Eddie
don't have to propose this one I think n
we can skip beyond everything else oh no
speakers to anyone secondly councillor
crumb
if you're all happy with that all those
in favor please show thank you very much
committee therefore resolves to grant
application 17 slashes zero two six six
eight slash ful this concludes business
for the night thank you